[Musique]
bonjour vous avez reconnu j'espère le
cri du cochon et oui le cochon en effet
va avoir la vedette dans notre émission
d'aujourd'hui d'abord parce que vous
avez vu la recette ce que va nous
préparer au pire on sait le pâté de tête
de tête de cochon bien sûr et puis parce
que le cochon environ c'est vous avez
une affection particulière pour le
codage cochon c'est le plat typique du
bistrot tous mangent dans le cochon
c'est vraiment de plat d'heure du
bistrot nous sommes contents attention
lui va toujours parlé il ya envie de
parler aussi des combo je vois mal
dernier cadeau tous les clients ramène
sur les catalans il faut dire que vous
collectionnez les cochons voilà on
collectionne les cochons et j'ai toute
une collection qui a commencé bêtement
en 82 ans a démarré avec ce cochon j'ai
acheté à l'as far de cassel au salon des
antiquaires avec une amie michelle et
c'était le premier cochon ensuite mon
petit apprenti m'a ramené à deuxième
motion pour me faire plaisir qui pelé
qui avait trouvé dans un antique a
également et on en avait deux essais
après que ça a démarré comme ça les
cochons du bistrot pirro ça y est la
collection donnacona 250 en ce moment et
tous les clients les clients qu'on amène
pas mal et c'est assez plaisant
voyez on navire par exor c'est les
petites tirelires bon là on trouve dans
les antiquaires ici une petite sauce
hier avec le comprend par le bas pour
que le grand reste en haut on a des
collectifs en voyage on l'est évidemment
collectivement voyage ça c'est des
cochons qui vient du mexique qui vous
ramener sa du mexique voile alors on
sait que si on veut vous faire plaisir
on ramène qui convient aux pierrots ou
un livre sur le cochon passe voilà il ya
beaucoup de coaches ont alors mené à
mort t1 dernièrement et c'est plaisant
de voir tous ces cochons qui rêve de
tous les coins
encore là il ya une petite partie de la
collection il y en a aussi chez vous qui
sont très intéressants au moins on piron
et notre assistance france à l'étalé le
film est d'ailleurs havas site agréable
[Musique]
et
non
[Musique]
où
pas super mais quelle est leur type
lawrence piro ya une phrase à la fin de
ces mois ont pas toi qu'est-ce que c'est
important
attention qui fait à ce mode celle mi
temps de ce nourriture ça veut dire
qu'en te faire ta match va chez le
moitié de ta vie quoi tu es heureux
comme touriste et un peu à dicton du
nord s'est fait voilà au slam libre où
le cochon en liberté liberté eh ben ils
se portent mieux que hewitt enfermé
voilà c'est vrai et alors bon alors de
cochon donc on l'a dit ça va être aussi
la vedette de la recette d'aujourd'hui
le pâté de tête
aujourd'hui on a fait donc à pâté de
tête alors cliquer déjà en train de vie
est en train de fuir alors il fuit
depuis trois heures à peu près on l'a
écrit ce matin de bonne heure et il fuit
depuis trois heures et disons pour l'ami
à cuire tout simplement avec du thym du
laurier d oignon piqué du tout j rock et
du gros sel votre art du gros sel vous
en mettez une de poignet chaque fois un
petit peu vague parce qu'on me reproche
que les proportions mais si vous laissez
les pendouiller for sale ou pas de façon
rectifiera l'assaisonnement et ça cuit
pendant 2h30 à 3h dans la marmite voyait
tout fier peuple on allait ma grand mère
il est pratiquement prêt voilà on y est
cuit alors évidemment vous pouvez
remarquer à quoi il ya une demi tagliani
2007 de cochon
on a deux mille têtes et que vous
demandez à votre boucher et vous avez
remarqué quelque chose
les oreilles sont coupées ou à l'oeil et
l'oreille parce que sous les gars du
cartilage sûr mais dans notre pâté de
tête ça bien croquants et tout le monde
n'aime pas le donc on la cuisson
l'oreille et tout reste l'ami alors ce
qu'on va faire on va simplement le
sortir
bon j'espère que tout le monde a bien
pris note des ingrédients donc vers le
bozec ou de girofle thym laurier du gros
sel
alors pour être une carotte thomas
pot-au-feu voilà alors et regardez elle
est bien cuit je vais donc enlevé
j'espère qu'on la voit bien oui
attention voilà je fais six étrangers
comme ça nous serons bien pour
travailler je vais enlever alors là
c'est un travail de charcutier presque
va garder comme ça et cuit oui ça s'est
fait tout seul alors j'enlève ma viande
de maison alors le pâté tête c'est une
recette vraiment agréable à faire et
dans les restaurants bon allez un peu
trafiqué ou dans les boucheries parce
que tout le monde rajoute beaucoup de
bouillon beaucoup toujours pareil pour
faire beaucoup plus de volume mais
normalement je passais peut-être c'est
un pâté de viande n'a pas tellement de
peur d'envoyer pierre à la cuy trois
heures elle se déclare faute tout seul
donc je vais enlever voyez c'est pas
très compliqué à faire à la maison
ça va tout seul à cuillé vous le mettez
à cuire dans une marmite comme on l'a
fait car des sacs hui et il faut que
c'est cuit
donc en détache tout c'est la couenne la
viande et regardez c'est le cas de le
dire était tous un peu trop mais tout
s'est vraiment passé comme on faire la
campagne
ouais alors il vous reste peu la
mâchoire et ça va tout seul vraiment il
ya aucun trucage
regardez alors ce que vous mettez pas
c'est l'oeil ah bon il faut éviter que
ça vous regarde et voilà il ya plus que
la mâchoire soirée dans les déserts du
far west avait des dessins qu'envoyer
voilà alors il ya un peuple qu'est ce
qui reste là à peu près comme boire y à
peu près huit à neuf peut aller 8 à 900
grammes de viande à peu près donc j'ai
tout ma viande
j'espère qu'on le voit bien que je vais
couper simplement
avec mon couteau dans le plat oui c'est
vraiment à plat simple à faire soyez
savent même pas ça s'arrache tellement
que ses cris quand le plus au bout de
trois heures plus c'est cuit plus c'est
bon vous pouvez l'argument qui reste du
bouillon dedans évidemment si
puissamment gardé parce que toutes les
herbes que vous avez mise dans l'eau de
cuisson effectivement sa fumée alors la
viande voyez pierre on le hb très très
faim allons au bout d'un petit morceau
de viande
c'est ce que je gardais c'est assez salé
poivré et alors là il manque un soupçon
de sel donc j'en ai un peu de sel ça se
goûte accrue pas cru si on peut dire
mais pointe
voilà alors vous fièrement h et voyez la
consistance que seule force et le pape
et de viande au préalable si vous voulez
vous prenez à 12h02 les faits au
préalable avec le bouillon de votre
votre peau je fais donc elle milite de
geler comme d'habitude soit que vous
prenez un peu de gelée soit vous le
demandez à votre boucher mais donc j'ai
fait à 1002 les que je vais rajouter
dans mon dans ma viande
là c'est pour pour ni homo j'ai alors
voyez mon amie camille littler pour une
demi tête de cochon dans les restaurants
ça y est je vais encore dire l'autre
comprend on en met beaucoup plus parce
que plus il y en a qui sont en fait mais
là pour les leurs c'est vraiment
délicieux et on va rajouter nos petits
des salles de marché notre taille et
notre père style classique usées
préparer soigneusement alesi pierre
allait travailler un petit peu pas vous
faire du bien comme ça avec moi comme ça
je vois là aller retour est alors nommé
à peu près 1000 g d'échalotes ouais
voilà 100 g d'échalotes santé comme ça
sent bon
ouais
le père sur le père s'il pouvait mettre
tous y à peu près à pompe et de persil
haché 30 à 40 g de persil haché aux
données pour comment il commence notre
patte et commence à prendre cette 70e
louis beaux salaf die sa dégelée javel
et pour bien montrer s'ils voulaient
faire des voix lors il est laïque qui à
peu près pas ta 30 grammes d'ail ou si
on va tout mettre ensemble quand même
parce que ça va se fondre dans le pâté
est-ce que vous reconnaissez pierre
quand même voyez ce pâté peut-être
qu'ils commencent à arriver conduit
aussi des fois t'es tu persillée est ce
que vous faites simplement une fois vous
l'avez fait dans votre plat oui vous le
remettez en méchante et à chauffer 5 10
minutes simplement pour que ça saute ça
se mélange et que ça viendra d'un
mélange homogène et mon côté de tête et
fait avancer tout ça oui
cuire sa tête de poche ont tiré la
mâchoire et l'oeil vieira faire et c'est
facile n'a pas lâché m le thym le lag le
persil et chaleur rajouter son milite de
geler et regardez vous avez le cas
peut-être qu'ils aient fait qu'on va
mettre en terrine dans deux trois
minutes lectorat bouillie bon ça assez
beau il a affirmé oui quand sa bouille 4
5 minutes simplement pour lier jeu les
stops le mans le mettre dans ma terrine
avec une louche pour avoir le jurerait
calais comme ça sent bon pierre
ouais il ya de la viande 1 alors voilà
c'est vraiment le pâté de viande
il n'y a presque pas de geler il ya un
haut niveau sont liés et ce sera donc
vraiment là c'est vraiment copieux il ya
vraiment tout la tête
la wii par exemple il est quoi vous
doivent pas vous aurez là de vitesse
alors une 2007 passe à peu près 1 kg 2
pour ça je sais à peu près 1 900 g 1 qui
a acquis l'audois kg 5 et ya peu près
900 grammes de viande et elle rentre
juste dans ma terrible assez fait pour
on dirait quelqu'un devient organisé
d'ailleurs faut dire que c'est une
recette que vous connaissez pas ça c'est
la vraie cuisine bistrot et avaient
raison alors quand ces prêts comme ça la
magie n'est pas ici puisque le maître la
laisser refroidir un petit peu et la met
au frigo et au bout de 4 5h ou 6h on peu
déjà la manger donc allé à l'est figé et
on peut la découpe et puisque la genève
a figé
alors on s'aperçoit quand même que là
c'est surtout le pâté de viande de porc
c'est vraiment délicieux non alors
qu'hier comme d'habitude on va goûter
on va goûter mais mais j'en ai quand
même préparé une loque demi portion loeb
demi tête avait été cuites ce matin bon
on va la manger la sortir du frigo
regardez là même terrine way a alors
bien consistante et après la même parce
qu'on y va alors évidemment pour les
petites dames on connait bien alors là
je vais me couper ici et bien fait une
belle tranche sur l'assiette apprend le
mettra sur la tartine vous regardez on
connais bien on voit bien les morceaux
de neg le morceau devant le persil à
tous et alors là je l'aimé comme ça on
va le goûter comme on fait dans le nord
un gros morceau de viande sur un bout de
papier leurs doutes et moi ça
[Musique]
l'actuel